bake with me as I prep food for my husband's boys weekend at the cottage
I started off by making a couple loaves of sourdough bread
because you always need some bread
and then I made a big tray of macaroni and cheese
just a perfect little snack or lunch
and then their main meal was going to be some sourdough pizza
so I made the dough the night before 4
and then I just rolled it out in the morning and I suck the crust with cheese
so delicious because I wanted the pizza to just be stored in the freezer
so it was super quick for them
they could just throw in the oven
it's ready to go the secret is to pre bake the crust
put on all the toppings let it cool down and then just wrap it up
and then of course
I had to make a couple of treats
so I made some chocolate chip cookies and some sourdough banana bread muffins
they're so good and yeah that's everything